[Musique]
l école la gt ouais ça va mais je
préfère la q4 elle braque bien mieux
bonne journée monsieur
[Musique]
olivia sort pas part de vos biens des
paparazzis je fais n'importe quoi
râtelle contre avis
c'est idiot de se faire renverser par
une voiture à l'arrêt
dans ce
jeu valence quitter comme ça si on
retrouve l autre cas de la photo c'est
d'accord
olivia alan va sortir avec moi l'actrice
très connu oui celle qui est très bon
c'est ça avec moi à ces pays qui depuis
une plage et bars et
c'est parti
je dois faire quoi
et un dieu du saxophone non je suis pas
un dieu du sexe
[Musique]
une seconde vous pouvez me dire ce qui
se passe
[Musique]
ils causent pas sa quête de natel ville
de granby comme ce maillot je crois
cette avant première est une course
qu'il est pas ça pour que pour nicolas
des mails son
titre de quoi mon frère il est honnête
et gentil beau tonio j't'adore je suis
célèbre gossip ce qui est franchement à
terra
cemex suppose que j'ai essayé de la
convaincre de revenir avec moi mais
maintenant qu'elle t'a jules tête que
finalement tout cette comédie avec ont
prêté
quoi
non chez oh et s'est rien passé et j'ai
dormi avec mon pantalon regarde
[Musique]
une photo